welcome to gma3 what you need to know on
this Friday you know it's too bad it's
Friday is that yeah Amy robach and TJ
Holmes can help but poke fun at their
wild wheat which reminds us of this clip
from 2016 a question TJ may now be
asking himself should you keep your
relationship Under Wraps if you're
dating in the office well now that their
romance is no longer Under Wraps et's
learning more about how it impacts
things in the workplace the answer it
won't hey good morning America on this
very unproductive work day at the office
while it's only been days since news
first broke of their secret workplace
romance
et's learned the relationship's been
going on for quite some time and our
source reveals Amy and TJ won't face
disciplinary action explaining it's
because they're two consenting
co-workers who are equals in a
relationship we will spare you America
et's reached out to GMA and ABC for
comment as there's been no official word
from management addressing the
relationship but a source tells us
that's all anyone can talk about around
the office
meanwhile fans are digging up what now
feel like flirty moments from the past
another tip is to train with friends you
set the agenda you say here's the report
and at least you feel the excitement of
doing it with someone you don't feel
alone TJ isn't that your favorite song
he always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
so while nothing's changing at work
there has been some Fallout in their
personal lives keeping the romance alive
in any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes following the couple
deactivating their individual Instagram
accounts Amy's ex Andrew's shoes removed
all photos of his wife from his account
Andrew and I are in our second marriage
we have a blended family we have step
children and ETS confirmed they've
already sold the New York City Apartment
they once shared for a cool 5.2 million
dollars
it's tough to have two playbooks you
have to have one Playbook it's really
been a journey
2010
Bernie who's all
who's alt-rock Nation
back in 2012 TJ was asked how he and his
wife make it work there are no secrets
for a happy marriage it's obvious okay
you do the right thing you treat each
other well you respect each other as for
TJ and Amy well they've yet to directly
comment on their relationship except to
say TGIF it's ma3 what you need to know
on this Friday you know it's too bad
it's Friday it's been a great week you
saw this one to keep going and going and
going just to enjoy it big for yourself
I am very excited about the weekend
[Music]
thank you